the names yeah names are hard i don't
have any easy answer for that i vastly
envy
someone like uh jack vance who i think
has a just a magical gift for names one
of the things i love
most about jack vance is the character
names and the place names
they're just i don't know they're just
wonderful they just ring off the ear
um tolkien was similarly gifted you know
if you read some of that and you say
well it's like talking
there's like three names for everything
and uh
you know this is what the elves call it
this is what the dwarves call it this is
what the men of western has used to call
it a thousand years ago
but today's men call it something else
and you know it's like a hill
but fantasy names are tough because you
know it was easy i mean tolkien
there wasn't much to come before him and
he was also a linguist
he he spoke languages he spoke old norse
and old english and
was familiar with linguistic theory i
don't have any of that stuff
and i have all this other fantasy stuff
that's come between tolkien and my work
and these guys have like used all the
good names you know
okay here i have some mountains what do
i call them here the misty mountain no
tolkien just a misty mountain was the
pointy mountains not stupid
the rocky mountain was the rocky that's
good wait a minute this really is rocky
mountain
um you know so when i come up with
something that i
hope is cool like the frost fangs which
i came up with from my mountains that's
that's good i i like that ooh first time
someone's loaded everywhere
i think that's good so um
it's it's tough yes now i realize uh
they just said this is a fairly
difficult process
and i apologize if it seems a bit
trivial um but
as a fan of fantasy in general i find
myself
playing quite a bit of fantasy
role-playing games including
dungeons and dragons primarily so i'd be
honored if you could bestow upon me
a character name or at least make a
suggestion
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm really afraid i i don't know you
well enough too
i mean the name needs to fit the
character let's see
well i i can assure you that i'd make it
fit
what's your favorite family um
i guess i'm kind of a i gotta go gotta
go uh gotta stay true to the stark
family
[Applause]
okay well the starks are northerners
they're descended from the first
men so the name should probably be
something uh short
blunt that also describes something like
a stark or a stout
or or blunt how about blunt
thank you very much fan
reactions to characters to events
etcetera do you find most surprising for
better or worse
what what the fan reaction do i find
most surprising
yeah um
well i i i guess i find the level of
dislike for some characters surprising
um you know certain well
it depends on the character you know
there are a lot of people who
write me emails and i'm not surprised
that they dislike joffrey
but when i get these angry letters from
people who dislike sansa
or catelyn or
brienne that that does surprise me
um of course there are equal numbers of
people or perhaps greater number of
people who love those characters
i mean what i take particular pleasure
in is is the
the vision among my readers about these
characters because indeed
uh when i look at real people in the
real world
uh we don't agree on who we like you
know my
my favorite actor may be an actor that
you can't stand
uh i may vote for a politician that you
think is a scumball
and vice versa real people react to
other real people
in a variety of ways so you know when
you read a book and you have a hero and
everybody likes to hear it when you have
a villain and everybody
dislikes the villain that's probably a
sign that you're dealing with cardboard
characters
when you create a character that's real
enough so that some people like that
character some people hate that
character some people find the character
very annoying
some people identify with the character
then you've probably created a fairly
real character
and that's always what my you know my
goal is
here thank you thank
[Applause]
uh in the you book you mentioned that
there were a lot of uh a lot of rewrites
what character vexed you the most and
made it into your virtual trash more
than
any of the others is there one
particular or are there many
is there one character like which
character got the most rewrites you know
you're writing a chapter like i hate
that name the most rewrites
had to do with the marines not so it
really the whole host of characters who
uh gathered around marine you know i
kept restructuring those chapters
trying to decide what was the optimal
dramatic order for people to arrive
and before this event no no be better
after this event
or because it would change this event it
was before this event that i wanted it
to happen this way no it didn't
wait a minute this other character left
before that character so then
and i rewrote those chapters tons of
times and it drove me man
so i'm a wreck of a man that you see
before here
but i finally swamped it i think i hope
but you guys will be the ultimate judge
of that
thank you thank you